-You´re looking very good.
And I hear that you´ve
changed your diet a little bit.
-Little bit.
-You´re almost vegan.
-Well, I´m -- I hate to just say
I´m vegan or almost vegan,
´cause it´s truly a lifestyle.
But I have been exercising
vegan options,
and it´s -- Yeah, so, I just got
to stop eating meat and dairy.
But other than that...
-Yeah.
Those are the two that
really get you, huh?
-The only thing that´s keeping
me from -- I´m 90% there.
-Yeah. Those are
the two they say are
the sticking points
for most people.
-Exactly, exactly.
-Yeah.
-You know, when your friends
find out you´re almost vegan,
are they upset?
-Oh, my God.
But some of them --
But some people are like,
"How?", you know,
´cause they just can´t
wrap their head around it.
And I was like,
"Two years ago, if you said,
´Let´s go to
a vegan restaurant,´
I would have been like, Why?´"
But now some of them have
the right to be upset,
´cause I am, you know,
the guy at dinner like,
"Does it have dairy in it?"
-Oh, you´re that guy.
-"Was that made with
animal products?"
-You don´t have to
use that voice.
You can do it
in your regular voice.
I saw you at the Emmys.
You were with
your father at the Emmys.
-You were so nice and gracious.
-Well, he was so --
What a nice guy he was.
And did you guys have fun?
Your whole family was with you.
-It was great. It was great.
-Were there people you were
excited to meet or see?
-Oh, man.
You know, there´s so many,
but De Niro
sat like two seats --
right in front of me,
two seats down.
And then when
they announced his name --
like, he was nominated --
they said, "Robert De Niro."
I said, "Bobby D.!"
And, like,
he slowly, like, looks.
Like, he just turned, and,
you know -- My De Niro face.
-That´s a good De Niro face.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was good.
-Full disclosure --
that part didn´t happen.
But --
-He didn´t actually -- Yeah.
-Yeah, I just said,
"Bobby D.!", and nothing.
-Nothing happened.
I want to talk about
your show, "Ghosted."
You want to clarify,
because people might
hear the title
and think it´s about
something else.
But you want to
clarify the premise.
-It is not about going --
like, dating somebody
and then just disappearing
from their life.
It´s not that.
It´s really, you know,
dealing with ghosts.
And it could be titled
"Vampired" or "Monstered,"
´cause there´s all these
different entities we deal with.
-It´s like a comedy "X-Files,"
to some degree.
-Comedic "X-Files." Exactly.
If Mulder and Scully had jokes.
-And you have Adam Scott
as either your Mulder or Scully.
I´ll let you guys sort it out.
He´s very -- He´s an incredibly
talented, really funny guy.
And on the show,
you sort of play the skeptic.
-Yes.
-He plays the believer.
-But, in real life,
it´s the opposite.
-Opposite, yes.
He doesn´t believe
in anything, and I -- No.
He doesn´t believe in
that stuff,
and I just don´t think
we´re alone here.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-So do you believe in
extraterrestrials and stuff?
Do you believe in ghosts?
-All of that, yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
What´s the thing
you´re afraid of the most?
Is there something --
-Afraid of?
I don´t deal with being afraid.
-Okay. That´s good.
-Yeah, you know.
-Always nice.
See, ´cause if
I believed in that stuff,
I think I´d be terrified.
-I mean, scary movies scare me.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
Like, later on, after the fact,
like when I first moved to L.A.,
you know,
I was living alone and stuff
and I went to see "Sixth Sense"
and "Blair Witch Project,"
not knowing I was afraid of
scary movies at this point.
-Gotcha.
-And then I went home.
And I didn´t know
they were gonna affect me,
and then, like, I
heard something and I just said,
"They´re gonna have to
get me on the couch,
´cause I´m not moving anymore."
-That was it.
-Yeah, that was it.
So, then I haven´t seen
a scary movie since.
-Okay, that´s good.
-I don´t even like when they
put the billboards up.
Remember the one with
the doll recently?
"Annabelle" or something?
-"Annabelle," yeah.
-And you´re just driving.
"Aah!"
You know, I don´t want --
-You´re right.
There should be a billboard
two blocks earlier saying,
"If you don´t like scary movies,
make your next left."
-Exactly.
-You were at the Def Jam
25th anniversary show.
-Yes.
-And I was wondering,
because of that --
You´ve obviously been doing
the comedy for a long time.
Do you remember --
When you first started,
do you remember,
like, a first joke?
-Oh, man. Yes.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you want to hear it?
-Yeah, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you sure? No.
The very first joke I wrote
was something like,
"Jesus must have been black,
because, you know,
he must have hid all that
fish and bread in his afro."
So...there´s a story about Jesus
with fish and bread,
multiplying.
-Yeah.
-Okay, yeah.
-But you thought he didn´t
actually multiply it.
He hid it in his afro.
-Yeah, he just had a bunch...
-So you believe in E.T.s but not
that Jesus could make extra...
[ Laughter ]
And were your parents
supportive when you said,
"I want to do comedy"?
-No.
-Okay.
-I was a schoolteacher.
-Yeah, I remember.
-I remember father saying,
specifically --
He was like, "You´re gonna
lose that good job."
So, I´m glad I didn´t listen.
-Yeah.
But he must be happy now.
Got to be at the Emmys.
Are they very satisfied
with how it turned out?
-They´re happy, and my mother --
She´s got to
bring it down a notch.
She´ll just be at
the grocery store like --
at the checkout like,
"My son´s on ´The Office.´"
"Mom! What?!"
-Well, thanks so much
for being here.
-Oh, my pleasure, brother.